[Aplausos]
[Música]
ele sabe eu até cantava a mensagem acho
que a viagem tinha uma palestra fazendo
investigadores têm atravessou esta
palestra e pensei o que vou falar
daquela estrutura de trabalho de
professores nos trabalhos que ia fazer
uma coisa diferente
o inter tentava com de zaga lá e design
de 60 anos aqui mas o grafismo é por
segurar da mensagem em que estava como
de fogo na cabeça isso esse espírito
porque não vim para cá venceu mais
frango na oi eu acho que isso é
fantástico então fomos todos aparece
comprar seu show na maravilhosa que eu
acho o máximo e de faqueiros que as
pessoas precisam mesmo as visitas limpar
a cabeça como esfregona a limpar a
cabeça porque todos nós somos capazes
mas é um fofo sabe faca na real dada às
vezes temos medo é preciso ir lá no meu
neto e elkeson ele o que quiser mas
pensei livremente até porque as pessoas
às vezes então dentro de um quadrado
quem não consegue vencer e fora porque
não fique aí vai o porto vai ficar mal e
precisão de sempre desde que não ofenda
ninguém nesse passo por cima de ninguém
que ser mais empinada faça o que achar
que deve fazer que seja diferente porque
ninguém consegue dar um passo em frente
se não formos diferente isso é uma coisa
que eu aprendi em casa facilmente na
china uma família fantástica é que
tenhamos um coema na cozinha em que
dizia que os filhos não são seus filhos
são filhos e filhos da vida vem através
de não me pode obrigar os corpos mas não
as suas almas pudéssemos fazer em na
casa do amanhã que é de um poeta
vencedor libanês e que eu acho que de
facto estudantes a liberdade e os meus
pais que nunca pode esquecer
foram fantásticos e lá em casa todos nós
temos a nossa liberdade cada um à sua
maneira a linha nexus mapa dizer
n não precisa viajar só precisa ir à
varanda porque de facto a minha cabeça é
uma cabeça que não precisa andar muito
lado mas precisar de mim
é só não personagem porque é engraçado
porque eu com a minha loucura eu acho
que a minha loucura toda e se uma pessoa
que viveu um pouco doente nem um pouco
afastada do resto para poder criar
livremente e então é a do engenheiro é
que o absolve facto é contra aumentos
muito mais do que eu dizia me sempre se
precisar de alguma direção do personagem
mas nunca ninguém ficou mais fácil então
engraçado onde estava e na colômbia nos
trabalhos que fez estava em frente à
casa do gabriel garcía márquez que eu
acho que é mesmo que o fantástico e tem
a certeza que ela estava e tu finalistas
se eliza
estou aqui é na colômbia enfrenta a casa
de garcia martin e elas não deixam não
sabe quem é ele para eles não é bem essa
parte dizer que de facto fantástico
estar aqui e ele foi muito bom nome no
meu trabalho a fim de conhecer as
pessoas pela mãe da ásia a china a
medalhas américa a áfrica e o saber de
facto a anp ea maneira de estarmos no
mundo de sermos livres e temos um
espírito leve respeitar os outros é
pensar que as pessoas que pensam
diferente nós também estão certas
estudos nós conseguirmos fazer isso
amanhã seria fantástico facto era amp
maneira de conseguirmos por isso nosso
planeta no lugar certo de sermos todos
engraçado eo vivo num hotel em lisboa
porque há muitos anos que vive no hotel
só é o que eu faço aqui uma taxa e agora
há muitos brasileiros lá trabalhando e
saltão e vez nem eles vêem a braços e
despede-se nos turnos e abraços que fica
a olhar com aquele mais bonito
nós portugueses não temos muita coisa do
corda abraçar e acho que esse tão
importante as pessoas a fazer isso mas
em contrapartida presente e tenho um
arquiteto japonês que trabalha comigo lá
no twiter e crescer se toca e tanto eu
desde não não ninguém tem que modificar
porque nós não gostamos disso
então ao fim destes anos eu fui se
habituando e nós chegávamos a torre
dávamos dos verdinhos academia e no
princípio dizia eu não quero e depois de
um dia de 68 e short viver em portugal
que as pessoas vão dos agora até dá um
mas que as pessoas vão dos versos porque
em frança as pessoas dão três e eu
fiquei a olhar pra mim muito admiradas
triste e outro dia se não tiver isso mas
como são tão distintos mas as outras e
temos mesmo respeitar aqui às vezes tive
a nível de trabalho eu to lá até termos
a trabalhar e temos várias idéias e e
assim o facto de crer que é ter várias
pessoas de vários países é porque todos
pensamos de maneira diferente tudo
devemos a mesma coisa mas de uma maneira
totalmente diferente a princípio podemos
ganhar tantos prêmios ganhar tantas
coisas por facto somos várias cabeças
com vários universos sempre nós agora 01
até lisboa que se chama wrc ea lei no
primeiro dia quando cruzamos é o nome da
vez é sean na cena e se uma palavra
o revés em casa e eles não mas isso não
pode servir de sinal então aparece é
nojenta é a água e às vezes amigos mar
tem mas consegue chegar lá vinha com
isso nomes e até acho que já fez já mais
design que liga o taxista leve montá-lo
hotel e táxi e perguntei mas onde é
perto da ong fica este hotel que
finalmente ficou wc e ele não tinha
aberto entrei num táxi no aeroporto e
desligou o wcg
a senhora não me excluo o senhor dentro
do card e assim a minha senhora mas vai
ser esse nome é raiva e eles inês cunha
do rei quando os filmes e filho esse é o
máximo por facto até lembra mesmo quando
chegou ao hotel tem duas banheiras na
recessão
rc sim de gestão 2010 hobby como falhas
na cabeça é tem jesus luzes são duchas
os quartos não são quartos no chão
simplesmente casas de banho com a calma
dentro da casa de banho e e totalmente e
ingressar que as pessoas que chegam lá
vão a inauguração feita na semana
passada que surge uma assistente que
teclar meses tietê confortável espécie
que estava a pensar que esse só porque
deve ser e e eventos tanto porque de
facto em dois dias nós sentimos em
entrevista de televisão já são 30 e isto
por causa de facto com o número nome
diferente eis que eu acho que as pessoas
não podem ter medo de ser originais nós
temos de ser o ginástica comando tem
tantas pessoas no mundo e isso não foram
os originais mas eu eu costumo dizer
desde que sabe por que é que se faz e
ash e seja consistente seja um produto
que é de facto seja fantasma
não podemos ter medo de fazer e é e pra
mim é se quer dizer eu até gosto de
fazer peças originais mas sei que há
pessoas que fazem o trajeto de trabalho
também é tão bom ou melhor do que o meu
quer dizer eu acho que o mandado tem
vários grupos e as pessoas encontram-se
pro grupo c
e acho que esse grupo merece é ter uma
coisa bem feita é uma coisa que seja
premiuns quando as pessoas juveni meses
até lá pra cá e de ser pessoas jovens e
as jovens que a área destinada à
imprensa a jovem não tem idade a jovem é
uma pessoa que viveu até morrer desde
que deixe que seja jovem não vai dar pra
esse jovem agora ex milene zahar tantas
palavras da agora as chamadas novas
estão chegando
quando mas eu acho que de facto há
pessoas que têm 180 engraçado no dia de
sua inauguração
chegamos um senhor que o ps devia ter
uns 80 anos eu venho agradecer três
vezes e pensei que engraçado assinante
nada arte ser um conquistado um título
desses no dia que ele chutasse este
facto tem uma ideia já está claro que eu
pensei lá está um jovem de 30 anos e é
isso mesmo nós sempre jovens livres ter
um espírito livre um espírito é
engraçado por exemplo ele chegar à
tailândia e os meus amigos detalhando
que fato pensavam diferente de nós é
hoje o tufão não é disse
nesse nina é porque de facto tem vários
nomes é nesse salva menina
nesse zão areva é é a churrasco e 800
nomes diferença dentro destes novos e
ingressado nas filipinas
eu fui com um tinha então vá fazer um
trabalho e estava na tim estava estava
com o senhor que era um trecho da
embaixada e criaram sítio noras futuro
senhor dizia se não há hipótese nível e
depois porque eu disse porque eo ar
sílva silva vieira e city uma das coisas
que de facto eu aprender né em casa foi
que não interessa a nós gastamos nós
tínhamos que 60 dos temas que sempre a
inventar a e tenha facilidade de
trabalhar com todas as camadas da
sociedade e todas as pessoas são
fantásticas em que a pessoa que o
encontro só eu fiz enquanto fazer os
hotéis agora estou a fazer algum
trabalho mudar mesmo soldado será outro
dia você ver que aquela equipa vai
embora e talvez não a vou ver mais e as
pessoas que lutaram e trabalharam e ri
quando nós trabalhamos em equipa é tão
fácil se nos dermos também as coisas eu
lembro que quando cheguei uma vez a
lisboa para fazer uma falha
em que nós vamos demandar isso nós
levávamos gols nela é vinho madeira por
ser as pessoas e oferecemos aos
trabalhadores que estavam lá fora então
serão tão simpático para nós não por
causa das ofertas em as despesas por
causa da maneira sem saber como nós os
seguimos tratado e sempre que
precisávamos alguma coisa tenham conosco
que diziam se precisar de alguma coisa
não se preocupe que nós arranjamos e
necessitávamos as coisas todas o fato
era maneira simpática e agradável
contratávamos todos e vai às vezes hoje
que chegam ao sítio [ __ ] entram de
maneira tão na sair e sinceramente
quando olha para essas pessoas têm pena
belas que fez ainda não se encontraram
que uma pessoa quando se encontrou a
pessoa mais simples do mano fax uns se
redonda da sociedade este planeta em que
todos temos uma impressão digital
diferente
todos são diferentes todos temos o nosso
papel e todos somos tão importantes mas
são importantes e há pessoas que
esquecem disso e acho que a pessoa que
tal não é ou é mais ou a menos e isso eu
acho que são pessoas que estão dentro da
caixa que não tem o tal fra esse
espírito que é tão importante na vida tv
e ir pra mim dizendo uma das coisas
interessantes foi de fato quando estes
de gripe a designer é desse em casa
precisava de design eo juiz faz apoiaram
embora o painel pretende ter mais do que
as mesmas sejam que taxas que xeres ia
de 60 haia a ficar 13 anos atrás da
namorada da mãe diferente eles pai mesmo
que quer ser meu pai de sexta porque às
vezes eu achei e tal nem vender para os
gostos darling no primeiro dia quando os
réus boa e quando se vive a vida e
infelizmente - nada no palácio pombal no
e ada e era tão engraçado porque vinha
da madeira e é nossa foi nancy é claro
que é diferente da pronúncia do voa e os
nossos nomes também são diferentes muito
muito dentro
e eu nem cheguei lá o senhor trabalhava
na porta e disse tem uma taxa de dor eo
que é assim olhar pra ele ser o
madeirense o que é isso que disse não
saiba que o trt dor e às vezes uma coisa
de ter fechar parafusos e eu disse é uma
chave de fendas e diz olha eu acho que o
nosso nome é tentar melhor porque tem
racha o parafuso
e ingressar com as deserções de ontem
sou eu tenho orgulho desse madeirense
faz questão de falar sendo ao menos não
explicar com as pessoas não compreendem
as pessoas dizem que dá madeira está cá
há tantos anos e continuo a falar aqui e
disse vou continuar o resto da vida já
compreendeu o facto e um se uma pessoa
que estou muito bem comigo mesmo
simplesmente porque pretendia estar bem
como por ter eu em casa as pessoas
acreditavam em mim e isso é muito
importante porque quando uma pessoa quer
de nós nós aqui estamos de facto podemos
fazer o que quiser e às vezes e várias
pessoas que dizem e não sei se vou
conseguir ou não sei se vou fazer lá no
atle desse problema é uma palavra que
não existe e nem ele assume adicionar
não existe essa palavra problema existe
função e às vezes elas venham me pede
csn
nós temos de arranjar uma grande mudança
não é de facto estas grécia grandes
altitudes nós temos de arranjar na vida
porque nós vivemos um x tempos vivem
mais ativamente os mais intensamente que
o time mas não podemos primeiro minuto o
facto de vida passa tanta pressa e ontem
estava no pavilhão do atlântico e será o
inss a 98 foi há 20 anos faz 20 anos do
ano 91 está tão presente na nossa vida
já faz 20 anos a vida passa tanta pressa
e nós podemos tanto tempo com coisas não
têm interesse nenhum em retribuir quadro
com isso de fora por aqui porque não
temos um freio espírito e abraçados uns
aos outros e fazemos em equipe e
trabalhamos com os outros sempre tenho o
meu design center agora no funchal que
pra mim aquilo às vezes as pessoas e é
interessante que as pessoas vêm do
estrangeiro adoram porque é essa é
diferente é uma história dará uma
história que foi a história de dois
garotos do calhau precedentes entre os
meus calhaus que é de facto é adora
andar descalça também é uma liberdade
pessoal e ii e poder representar é que
os miúdos que andavam na rua o nosso
passado poder representar o tal lu
design que há 30 anos atrás na madeira
não era nada e que hoje ele é fugir meta
eu tive há muitos designers que são da
universidade da madeira e é só para
mostrar às pessoas que a elaborar novas
profissões profissões que nós nem
imaginamos o que é e que temos de apoiar
os nossos filhos e eu não quero ter
filhos meus filhos é o meu trabalho mas
temos de acreditar porque quando um ovo
chega à casa uma pessoa dizer se a
referir porque esse vídeo é por exemplo
ver james cook se vai ganhar a vida com
quem e não esquecemos que daqui a 20
anos que passa tanta pressa
quase tudo tão diferente é todo feito e
nós cremos na escola cabeça de deus mas
é impossível
quero vencer dez pessoas por facto o
mundo o homem é tão diferente do nosso
mundo e se nós pensarmos bem os nossos
avós diziam ah não existe uma loucura e
pra nós é normal
portanto é de deus não é loucura é
normal simplesmente não existe no nosso
universo por não existe no nosso
universo
nós pensamos que não tá certo e este é
difícil design center a mostrar fatah 30
anos não era e hoje em dia foi tem uma
equipe enorme prazer dentro ea china
fossem eles eu não estava aqui porque
tânio equipé lisboa em que panamá dara e
que são pessoas que fazem trabalhos
fantásticos a quem eu devo tudo o que
sou é els as pessoas que passaram na
minha vida aos meus parte e esta terra
maravilhosa que a ele é de mandar a que
eu adoro e que vai ficar sempre espera
uma grande energia para conseguir viajar
fumo
obrigada bom dia
[Aplausos]